[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing the events
of the order of the phoenix more
specifically we're going to be taking a
closer look
at dumbledore we know that it was during
this school year the dumbledore was
ousted from hogwarts
this was a terrible year for the school
not only was dumbledore gone
but umbridge was put in his place
eventually being appointed his mistress
this of course all transpired due to the
ministry namely fudge
continually butting heads with
dumbledore fudge was lashing out
he was blinded by fear and in utter
denial that the dark lord voldemort had
returned
dumbledore continually tried to convince
fudge of the truth
but his efforts were futile and fudge
continued to punish dumbledore
in whatever way he could eventually
things escalated
to a futile arrest attempt on dumbledore
by the ministry
who were they kidding and a fantastic
exit from the hogwarts grounds
but all of this raises one very big
question where did dumbledore go
he's kicked out of hogwarts and doesn't
turn up again until his duel with
voldemort in the ministry atrium
what gives the only place that we can
truly rule out is grimmauld place
as he immediately rejects that notion
when questioned by mcgonagall
where will you go dumbledore whispered
professor mcgonagall
gremelled place oh no said dumbledore
with a grim
smile i'm not leaving to go into hiding
the fudge will soon wish
he'd never dislodged me from hogwarts i
promise you
while under pursuit from the ministry
dumbledore didn't have too many options
for
safe havens as it's likely that the
ministry would find him
in some of the more obvious spots
however i'm not sure that dumbledore was
even particularly concerned
that they would find him after all if
they did find him what on earth could
they possibly do to detain
dumbledore now my first assumption would
be the dumbledore simply went horcrux
hunting
this seems like the obvious answer
dumbledore was wise
powerful and plenty of time on his hands
why would he waste his time
doing anything else to add to this later
that same summer
dumbledore was able to effectively
destroy marvolog's ring
which suggests that the topic was on his
mind
the issue with this however is that
dumbledore horcrux hunting
doesn't provide any kind of problems for
fudge before leaving
dumbledore very clearly says to
mcgonagall fudge will soon wish he'd
never dislodged me from hogwarts
i promise you this seemed to imply that
dumbledore had intentions of making
fudge's life difficult
but what did he mean by this what action
did he take
one thing i'd like to add is that for
the duration that dumbledore was gone
the ministry had absolutely no idea
where he was
this is reinforced by the following
conversation between march banks and
umbridge journey was fine journey was
fine we've made it plenty of times
before
she said impatiently now i haven't heard
from dumbledore lately
she added peering around the hall as
though hopefully he might suddenly
emerge from a broom cupboard
no idea where he is i suppose none at
all
said umbridge shooting a malevolent look
at harry ron and hermione who were now
dawdling around the foot of the stairs
as ron pretended to do up his shoelace
but i dare say the ministry of magic
will track him down
soon enough here are the facts
dumbledore was wanted by the ministry
he expressed that he had no intention of
hiding he vowed that fudge would regret
his decision
and he destroyed the gaunt ring shortly
after his departure
what's the best way that dumbledore
could make fudge regret his decision
proving him wrong i think that while
away dumbledore spent his time
doing a few things working to raise
awareness about voldemort's return
hunting horcruxes and trying to expose
voldemort
the best way to make fudge regret his
decision would be to expose him as
wrong effectively jeopardizing the
safety of the wizarding world
because of his own denial furthermore
dumbledore was the only wizard that
could properly challenge voldemort
the most powerful wizard on the good
side and i think that becomes abundantly
clear to fudge
when he finally arrives at the ministry
atrium and feasts his eyes on voldemort
once more
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you